[Musik]
das ist mein onkel erst am 25 september
2016 verstorben an
bauchspeicheldrüsenkrebs
eigentlich wollte er seine organe
spenden was durch den krebs nicht mehr
möglich war
daher hatte ich dann zur körperspende
entschieden natürlich geht man auch wenn
mir sehr aber ich bin auch stolz drauf
das hat sich entschieden hat den jungen
leuten die chance wird ganz ganz viel
für ihren weiteren berufsweg mitzunehmen
also ich arbeite zum ersten mal an der
leiche der ersten moment war für mich
ein schock moment so ich habe vorher
noch nie eine leiche gesehen tatsächlich
modell zu sehen das ist schon sehr
faszinierend die bestattung meines
onkels von knapp zwei jahre nach dem air
verstorben war stadt zwar sehr würde
voll dankbarkeit kam sehr gut rüber
[Musik]